[Musique]
bonsoir bienvenue dans le journal de tv
78 une édition pour faire le tour de
l'actualité locale voici les titres de
ce mercredi 20 janvier
c'est un des chantiers les plus
conséquents en matière de transports en
ile-de-france le rer e doit être
prolongée de paris à mantes la jolie à
l'horizon 2024 et les travaux se
poursuivent notamment dans les yvelines
où une troisième voie écrit à proximité
directe de la scène
le point avec et xavier gruz directeur
du projet eole rencontre avec sophie
fourmaux qui exercent une profession
rares cet abat juristes de
voisins-le-bretonneux a reçu récemment
le trophée savoir-faire du concours
créatrice d'avenir une reconnaissance
qui va lui permettre de s'agrandir et de
transmettre sa passion
et puis cet ouvrage de 1932 va bientôt
disparaître le moulin de saint cyr va
être rachetée et détruit par versailles
grand parc
un projet d'envergure en vue des jo-2000
24 troupes tout proche du site olympique
des épreuves équestres
à suivre également dans ce journal un
nouvel espace pour le coworking ouvert à
saint germain en laye et c'est dans une
ancienne gare
actualité autour des transports
aujourd'hui dans ce journal avec tout
d'abord des perturbations à prévoir
demain jeudi sur les rer a et b
l'intersyndicale de la ratp appelle les
conducteurs à la grève la raison
protester contre des pression
managériale constante et la non
reconnaissance financière et de ce fait
vos conditions de circulation seront
compliqués demain sur les deux lignes
vous le voyez prévoir un train sur deux
pour le rer à 1 train sur 2 également
pour le rer b mais aux heures creuses 2
2 rames sur 3 circuleront en revanche
aux heures de pointe plus d'informations
sur le site de la ratp
le projet d'extension du rer e vers
l'ouest se poursuit le prévoit à terme
d'un prolongement est de 55 km de paris
à mantes la jolie pour en parler et
xavier gruz est avec nous bonsoir
bonsoir par visioconférence vous êtes le
directeur de ce projet nommé éole dans
un instant on fait le point sur le
dossier avec vous reportage d'abord sur
un chantier de la ligne entre et poney
mantes-la-jolie nous une troisième voie
est en cours de création actuellement
d'ailleurs une partie de cet ouvrage est
construit directement sur la scène les
précisions d'astrid bergère les travaux
de prolongement du rer e avance l'un des
gros chantiers de ce projet c'est la
création de cette troisième voie le but
du travaux est de créer une voie
supplémentaire entre les garder paul
mézières et dément station soit environ
3 km
cette voie permettra de fluidifier le
trafic ferroviaire et apportera de la
robustesse et améliorer la régularité de
l'exploitation ferroviaire en cas de
retard d'un train d'une panne ou d'une
plus faible vitesse sur l'une des deux
voies
un dépassement pourra être possible sur
cette troisième voie et pour la créer et
conserver un chemin pour piétons et
cyclistes
il a fallu construire sur la scène nous
sommes ici au droit du futur chemin du
halage
donc dans le cas de travaux nous avons
énergie de 4 m la berge avec un mur de
soutènement palplanches pour permettre
de maintenir ce chemin de halage au
public à l'issue de nos travaux jusqu'à
100 personnes travaillent
quotidiennement sur le chantier de cette
troisième voie aujourd'hui on est sur
les travaux de génie civil itinera
cement en cours
nous commençons aussi la pose des
équipements ferroviaires notamment les
supports caténaire la poste de travaux
voix commenceront au mois de mars de
cette année les travaux sont prévus
jusque août 2023 avec la mise en service
avec de tels travaux il a fallu penser à
la faune et la flore les plantes rares
présentes sur les sites ont été
replantés ailleurs et un espace pour
favoriser la reproduction des poissons
va être aménagée saviez gruge une
question me vient en voyant ce sujet
avant que l'on parle plus généralement
de ce projet de rer e du prolongement de
ce rer e on sait que la scène est
parfois capricieuse avec un fleuve qui
sort parfois de son lit que se
passe-t-il justement cas d'inondation de
ces bois a pas écoutés on a
effectivement intégré le risque de crue
et on sait que cela va être important
d'abonnés décrue déjà importante sur le
chantier donc on a tout un plan de repli
en cas de demande et de l'as être
l'objectif c'est bien sûr éviter toute
dégradation du milieu naturel pollution
et autres et puis également pour dégager
les volumes qu'on pourrait occuper dans
le dans l'oubli donc ça ça fait partie
des éléments ce qu'elle en est engagé il
ya un sujet extrêmement précis et
rigoureux qu'elle fait et donc en cas de
crue ses plans soient activés en lien
très étroit avec les services de l'état
services de police de l'eau et donc ses
élans qui sont totalement intégrés dans
nos politiques environnementales alors
je le disais avant le sujet vous êtes le
directeur du projet eole c'est un
chantier titanesque qui se poursuit
entamé depuis 2016 le prolongement du
rer e prévoit de relier les gares
d'haussmann saint lazare à l'ouest de
l'ile-de-france terminus mantes la jolie
pourquoi c'est une future offre
intéressante pour les utilisateurs de
transports en ile-de-france pourquoi
finalement il fallait cette connexion
avec l'ouest de l'île de france
aujourd'hui les axes importants
déplacements en ile-de-france en
transports en commun en particulier
celles axe est-ouest
le rer a est la plus chargée aujourd'hui
du réseau est ouvert et donc l'objectif
c'est de venir soulager cette ligne qui
était déjà très chargé de venir aussi là
le double salaire si un problème sur le
rer a d'abord unafec d'infrastructures
les capacités équivalentes
l'enjeu est aussi du projet eole c'est
de venir améliorer sensiblement la
desserte de la vallée de la seine
jusqu'à mantes la jolie et donc
l'objectif du projet c'est d'améliorer
cette desserte de manière très
substantielles ont quasiment tous blancs
l'offre par rapport à l'énergie actuelle
les trains aujourd'hui qu'ils vont
jusqu'à mende sont assurés par cette
ligne l'adjectif d'offrir deux fois plus
de trains avec notamment 4 1 toute la
journée tous les quarts d'heure un train
dans les deux sens qui permet de relier
menthe et toutes les villes de la vallée
de la seine à la partie la partie
centrale paris et et il dément toute la
desserte du centre de l'agglomération
parisienne et concrètement combien de
temps de circulation autrement tu es
cette partie centrale
à paris on aura des temps de trajet qui
dépendront du duo nombre d'arrêts l'on
sera très important de l'ordre de 40
minutes
donc ça sera évidemment une offre
beaucoup plus soutenu je n'ai aussi dans
le sens de la co entreprise s'appelle un
contrepoint le matin notamment pour
revenir à 2-2 delà de paris ou des
secteurs delà des hauts-de-seine vers le
mantois
et c'est donc notamment aussi très
important pour l'offre qu'on en est
capable d'offrir aux employeurs qui sont
dans ces secteurs là et l'objectif c'est
vraiment d'avoir cette augmentation très
sensible de l'offre
et quand on augmente l'offre régulé
comme pas ou bien sûr on a moins
d'attentes
alors c'est un chantier avec de
livraison d'abord le prolongement de 8
km en sous-sol de semaine saint lazare à
nanterre qui doit ouvrir en 2022
prolongement suite de 47 km jusqu'à
mantes la jolie
lui qui est prévu pour 2024 pour cette
mise en service est ce que malgré la
crise sanitaire qui on le sait a pu
causer des retards sur bien bien
enfin sur beaucoup de chantiers pardon
est-ce que les temps les timings vont
pouvoir être tenus correctement on a été
très affecté par la crise comme idée le
premier compliment mais complètement
tous les chantiers se sont arrêtées
brutalement deux jours on a eu un arrêt
complet de la production sur le chantier
on à terre des premiers chantiers à
reprendre dès le 6 avril donc entre le
17 mars et 6 avril bis écoulé à peine
trois semaines on a eu des premiers
reprise très partiel au démarrage une
accélération à partir de mi avril et mi
me joindre devenu quasiment à une
production normale sur nos chantiers le
deuxième confinement n'a pas eu d'impact
qui vont de production et donc on a fait
un très gros travail de consolidation
lequel on verra quel était l'impact
global de ces interruptions sur le
soleil des travaux ou au global on a
bouclé cette analyse sur la section
centrale est donc ce qui était prévu et
d'être mis en service fin 2022 donc le
prolongement jusqu à nanterre sera mis
en service mi 2023 et sur le service
jusqu'à mantes en a pour l'instant on
est encore en travail de consolidation
mais on a pas on a maintenu la date de
fin 2024 et donc ça fait partie des
points qui font rencontrons solide on a
eu beaucoup de perturbations sur
certaines études en particulier donc ça
départ titres avec en train de faire ce
qu'on peut dire c'est qu'on est tous
très mobilisés pour la tenue des délais
et le démarrage du chantier notamment
dans le secteur de menton on a commencé
les travaux du bief du kili des travaux
et des travaux importants et les yeux
essentielle pour la création du corps a
donné ces travaux ont bien démarré comme
prévu alors quelques mois de retard on
l'a compris justement sur les travaux
vous parlez des travaux sur l'axé on va
dire yvelinois le prolongement vers
l'ouest on s'appuie davantage sur du
réseau existant que l'on va consolider
et à paris on a dû creuser de nouvelles
voies c'est ça en termes de en termes de
chantier effectivement le projet
prévoyait une section nouvelles dans
paris puisqu'aujourd'hui on n'avait pas
d'infrastructures qui permettait de
faire passer les trains et puis c'était
une modernisation et une amélioration
des infrastructures entre nanterre et
aimante dont on utilise l'infrastructure
actuelle et on vient se substituer au
train d'être un érudit en biens est
remplacé par dr
heureux biens matériels beaucoup plus
capacitaire confortable moderne
climatisée avec des services dans ces
femmes qu'on a pas dans les trains
actuels modernisation complète de delors
en réutilisant l'infrastructure et la
modernisant on a fait des gros travaux à
poissy pour augmenter la capacité de la
gare de poissy c'est découvrir ce qui
l'est davantage de trains et plus
rapidement on va faire la même opération
amante mentons pas quasiment rebond sur
la totalité des infrastructures
ferroviaires d'une augmente et cette
amélioration qualitative de
l'infrastructure va permettre
d'augmenter de moitié le nombre de
trains et c'est ce qu'on vise avec ce
projet ce projet une dernière question
sur le tronçon parisien j'ai vu que les
trains pourront circuler jusqu'à 120 km
heure avec une fréquence beaucoup plus
soutenu c'est ça exactement des trains
qui rompt qui iront plus vite que
l'éclair actuelle 120 kilomètres heure
il est de loin la vitesse la plus
importante sur le réseau rer et c'est
également des trains qui a une capacité
d'accélération et de freinage plus
importante et donc ça ça fait partie
avec les passer en va aussi de retrouver
dans le mantois avec des trains qui
effectivement au rang de les dire une
capacité à redémarrer vitalité du temps
donc c'est vraiment d'être un très bon
signal pour mettre en place et ça ça va
également contribuer très fortement à
l'amélioration du service d'ordre dans
la vallée dans la vallée de la seine et
jusqu'à quand
merci et xavier gruz d'avoir est avec
nous et je landry directeur du projet
eole je vous le rappelle donc une
arrivée prévue à mantes la jolie pour
2024 il est possible de retrouver
d'ailleurs les différents chantiers en
cours et de suivre aussi un le
calendrier sur le site qui s'affiche en
bas de l'écran
un dernier mot de transport avant de
parler d'autre chose il est désormais
possible de disposer de son passe navigo
sur son smartphone la fonctionnalité
existait déjà sur les appareils android
et l'est depuis aujourd'hui sur les
appareils iphone vous pouvez donc
désormais recharger se passe virtuel
avec différents forfaits à la journée au
mois ou à l'année dans quelques semaines
il sera également possible d'acheter des
tickets à l'unité directement avec votre
téléphone
c'est une nouvelle étape vers la
dématérialisation définitive du ticket
de métro 550 millions et de ces bouts de
cartons sont utilisés chaque année en
france
partons maintenant à la rencontre d'une
créatrice sophie fort mauvais tabac
juriste elle est installée à voisins le
bretonneux en décembre dernier
l'illinois a reçu le trophée
savoir-faire du concours créatrice
d'avenir ce qui va lui permettre de
pouvoir transmettre sa profession
devenues rares mélanie poké vous avez la
technique
donc je suis en train de réaliser et à
la technique du contrecollé donc c'est
prendre un pot lifan et contrecollé soit
du tissu soit du papier l'émotion passée
sophie fourmaux a repris le chemin de
son atelier mais ce prix est une
reconnaissance et va lui permettre de
s'agrandir et de transmettre sa passion
j'espère susciter des vocations alors
soit des personnes qui ne veulent se
reconvertir et pourquoi pas dans les
abats jours ou alors des jeunes qui
veulent faire des apprentissages
donc ça j'aimerais bien parce que je
recrute il montré que les métiers d'art
c'est aussi des métiers qui commencent à
mourir peu à peu mais il n'ya pas que
nous il ya aussi les fournisseurs
c'est aussi toute une chaîne après
quinze années dans l'événementiel sauf
il veut travailler de ses mains
passionné d'un objet du quotidien
inattendu pied de lampe
elle se dirige vers le métier
d'abat-jour east elle est créée avec du
papier du japon pour moi c'est quelque
chose assez magique et après c'est
construire un projet de lumière avec le
client donc ils viennent avec leurs
pieds de long plus peut-être lampe il
faut savoir que c'est un objet qui est
très affectif le papier japonais c'est
donc c'est un papier que je travaille
depuis je suis tout petit puisque je
fais de l'origami depuis fait tout petit
ou du kerrigan ou est ce qui me plaît
dans le papier japonais c'est les motifs
en fait et chaque motif représente un
motif qui se trouve sur les kimonos
japonais aussi bien hommes que femmes et
chaque motif et à une symbolique
travaillant principalement pour les
particuliers sophie fourmaux souhaite
s'ouvrir vers les professionnels grâce à
ce prix elle regarde vers l'avenir
elle crée près de 1700 abat jours par an
à saint germain en laye l'ancienne gare
de la grande ceinture connaît une
nouvelle vie lors des étages du bâtiment
a été investie voici peu par un espace
de coworking son nom la ruche pour
permettre aux entrepreneurs de
développer leurs idées
présentation avec bixente mais rien
senti steban ce mardi 19 janvier vous
auriez pu entendre un léger
bourdonnement est maintenant de
l'ancienne gare de la grande ceinture
après plusieurs mois de travaux la ruche
de saint germain en laye a ouvert ce
nouvel espace de coworking la ruche de
saint germain en laye à deux activités
principales
une première activité c'est du coworking
donc on accueille des gens qui viennent
travailler sur le lieu qui profitent de
tous les espaces qu'on a pensé comme un
parcours d'innovation pour développer
des projets autour du développement
durable et l'innovation sociale et puis
on a des programmes d'incubation qui
permettent à des entrepreneurs de
profiter d'un accompagnement sur 3 6 à 9
mois un accompagnement intensif pour
développer et accélérer leurs projets
c'est un dessin de 50 entrepreneurs déjà
rassemblés pour butiner dans un étage
divisé en cinq parties et suivant un
certain parcours espace café puis celle
de co création de partage de décisions
pour amener au dernier palier
et puis la dernière étape voilà pour
s'envoler en a imaginé de piquerouge
beaucoup plus grande qui permet de
développer
idées auprès de financeurs ou d'associer
potentiel l'ellure aujourd'hui c'est
premier étage alors qu'auparavant on
était uniquement sur le rez de chaussée
c'est vrai que c'est assez agréable de
découvrir ce nouvel espace pour les élus
partenaires du projet l'emplacement de
ce nouveau centre d'activité n'a pas été
laissé au hasard
on voulait que ce lieu s'implante au
niveau de la gare de la grande ceinture
qui était un lieu historique
emblématique de l'histoire de la ville
et qui retrouve dans un quartier qui
retrouve toute une nouvelle dynamique et
en développement puis surtout le tram 13
qui est là dont les travaux sont bientôt
terminées et donc voilà il faut à dos et
l'activité l'énergie à côté des moyens
de transport et des moyens de transports
doux un projet financé par plusieurs
organismes publics et privés à hauteur
de 600 mille euros en tant qu'acteur
majeur de développement économique dans
l'actualité nous avons appris cette
disparition hier catherine rich est
décédé lundi à l'hôpital bichat après un
malaise elle avait 88 ans la comédienne
connue notamment pour sa carrière au
théâtre a été nommé à six reprises aux
molières et déroulent également à la
télévision dans la série les grandes
familles ou encore au cinéma dans va
voir maman papa travaille elle était
l'épousé de claude rich disparu en 2017
c'est d'ailleurs dans la même église que
son défunt mari saints-pierre-et-paul
d'orgeval que se dérouleront les
obsèques ce vendredi à 15h c'est un
dossier à enjeu en vue des jeux
olympiques de 2024 à paris le moulin de
saint cyr à proximité directe du site
des épreuves équestres doit être
prochainement racheter et détruit et 2,3
millions d'euros ont été débloqués par
l'état pour accompagner ce dossier
bixente maria santisteva n'a construit
en 1932 le moulin de saint cyr doit
prochainement être rachetées et détruit
pour cause son esthétique ainsi que sa
proximité avec le parc du château de
versailles qu'un seul mur et ses parts
dans le cas de cette préparation des
jeux toulon s'est rendu compte que ce
moulin devait disparaître
ah bon parce que c'est vraiment le lieu
où il y aura des épreuves d'équitation
et donc il faut mais quelque chose qui
soit qui correspondent plus
la beauté du parc du château ce projet
s'inscrit dans la rénovation de l'allée
royale de villepreux où se trouve le
site de l'étoile royale qui accueillera
en 2024 les épreuves équestres des jeux
olympiques de paris le bâtiment devait
d'abord être transformé en tient lieu
mais c'est finalement un parking de 150
places qui sera construit c'est assez
paradoxal est que c'est les élus ils se
sont mobilisés
rami leurs situations et qu'on fait
l'état lui-même
une fois que j'utilisais lice mobilisés
a mis la barre très haut il détruire le
bâtiment
il estime en effet l'objectif est de
dégager et mettre en valeur ce passage
vers le parc du château afin que
promeneurs et joggeurs puissent s'y
rendre en se garant à proximité
je crois que les habitants ils sont très
contents d'avoir une perspective est
sûre le château eagle ont créé une
pression supplémentaire
j'ai toujours écouté cette entrée et
nature et il faut les exploiter
parmi les autres plan de valorisation de
cet espace la future ligne 13 du tramway
qui reliera saint germain en laye à
saint cyr un arrêt devant cette entrée
du parc du château est prévue et puis
elle justement rêve des jo de 2024 la
golfeuse manon dit daly a réalisé à 27
ans l'une des meilleures saisons de sa
carrière en 2020
la sportive s'entraînait régulièrement
au club de la boulie à versailles son
portrait par michael et demi d'euros
trouver le bon mouvement le bon dosage
régulièrement la golfeuse
professionnelle manon jdli 27 ans répète
ses gammes sur les parcours libinois et
notamment sur celui du golf de la boulie
à versailles un cocon qu'elle a rejoint
à l'âge de 14 ans ç'a toujours été un
grand club
depuis tout peut marcher arrivé ici à
l'âge de 14 ans et c'est vrai que le
racing c'était le club sportif avec les
tous les bons espoirs
et donc c'était j'étais vraiment ravi
d'être accueillis ici et j'étais surtout
très fier de pouvoir représenter le club
un golfeur ça de pouvoir me battre pour
les couleurs bleu ciel et blanc sur
l'apprentissage du haut niveau est
également passé par les états unis à 18
ans la golfeuse parfaire ses études en
l'université d'arizona pendant quatre
années un vrai plus seulement 7 fans de
tiger woods quand je suis arrivé là bas
c'était vraiment une autre dimension
c'est à dire que là bas les
infrastructures tout est mis en place
pour le sportif pour qu'il se sente bien
pour qu'ils peuvent
j'ai appris beaucoup de choses surtout
notamment par rapport à l'aspect un peu
mentale l'aspect stratégique très
positif là bas ils sont vraiment ce
testing belle espérance de vie une
expérience bénéfique en 2016 m'allonge
idali passe professionnel elle est
aujourd'hui la quatrième français sur le
ladies european tour après une année
2009 a réussi là j'ai eu deux années qui
ont été plutôt satisfaisante la cette
année je fini 33e européenne au ranking
ça a été ma meilleure année depuis mon
passage prolongé dali veut continuer sa
progression pour accomplir ses rêves
participer un jour à une solesmes kep
les compétitions qui oppose l'europe aux
états unis maintenant j'ai des lièvres
également faire partie de l'aventuré des
jeux olympiques de 2024
il va falloir gagner des tournois il va
faire performer parce que il faut
marquer pas mal de point au niveau
ranking mondial et le ranking mondial
malheureusement quand on est en europe
c'est dur de marquer des points par
rapport au tournoi qui aux états unis
donc va falloir parfait en europe avant
de penser aux jeux olympiques m'allonger
delhi espère réussir sa rentrée sur le
circuit européen en 2021 objectif de sa
saison remporter une victoire et
intégrer le top 15 en fin d'année
c'est la fin de ce journal merci de
votre fidélité dans un instant un
nouveau numéro du 7 8 sociétés en ce
jour de l'ouverture des voeux sur
parcours sup mélanie poquet posera une
question à ses invités l'orientation
scolaire est-elle plus difficile en ces
temps de kobe de 19 c tout à l'heure
belle soirée avec tv 78
[Musique]